Oxytocin has been called the love hormone. But recent research has shown that the brain chemical may play a role in regulating our moral behaviors, earning itself another nickname, the moral molecule. In this episode, psychologist Paul Zach talks about his research into oxytocin's impact on how we interact with one another face-to-face and even virtually. I'm Andre Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Paul Zach is the founding director of the Center for Neuroeconomic Studies and Professor of Economics, Psychology, and Management at Claremont Graduate University. He studies the brain chemical oxytocin and its impact on behaviors and personality.
催产素被称为爱情激素。但最近的研究表明，这种大脑化学物质可能在调节我们的道德行为方面发挥作用，因而赢得了另一个绰号——道德分子。在本期节目中，心理学家保罗·扎克谈论了他对催产素如何影响我们面对面甚至虚拟互动方式的研究。我是安德烈·汉密尔顿，这里是“心理学访谈”。保罗·扎克是神经经济学研究中心的创始主任，也是克莱蒙特研究生大学的经济学、心理学和管理学教授。他研究大脑化学物质催产素及其对行为和人格的影响。
His book, The Moral Molecule, The Source of Love and Prosperity, was published in 2012. Welcome, Dr. Zach. Thank you. Happy to be here. We want to know. What is oxytocin? Why do you call it the moral molecule? So oxytocin is a chemical the brain makes.
他的书《道德分子：爱与繁荣的源泉》于2012年出版。欢迎你，扎克博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。我们想知道：什么是催产素？你为什么称它为道德分子？催产素是大脑产生的一种化学物质。
It functions both as a hormone, which means it affects parts of the body outside the brain, and in the brain it actually affects brain activity. And it was known only to be released in humans during birth and breastfeeding and during sex. But it turns out, in studies we started doing about a dozen years ago, that there are many other stimuli that cause the brain to release oxytocin. And when oxytocin is released, we connect to other people. We care about other people in tangible ways. So we've done experiments where we tempt people with virtue advice by putting money on the table.
它的功能既是一种激素（这意味着它会影响大脑以外身体的其他部位），又能在脑内实际影响大脑活动。人们原以为它只在人类分娩、母乳喂养和性行为期间释放。但在我们大约十二年前开始的研究中发现，还有许多其他刺激会导致大脑释放催产素。当催产素释放时，我们会与其他人建立联系。我们会以切实的方式关心他人。因此，我们做过这样的实验：通过在桌上放钱来诱使人们进行美德选择。
And when people release oxytocin or when we give them synthetic oxytocin, they're much more likely to engage in positive social behaviors, what we would call moral behaviors, because of oxytocin. We've taken blood before and after, different social stimuli, positive social stimuli, like dancing, like singing, like sharing, people praying, meditating, all these things done in a group, release oxytocin, and subsequently follow the money. So see what people do with the money
当人们释放催产素时，或者当我们给他们注射合成催产素时，他们由于催产素的作用，更有可能从事积极的社会行为，也就是我们所说的道德行为。我们在不同的社会刺激（如积极的社会刺激：跳舞、唱歌、分享、人们祈祷、冥想，所有这些在群体中做的事情）前后提取了血液，这些都会释放催产素，随后关注金钱的去向。看看人们如何处理这些钱
once they've released oxytocin, and we see that we can actually turn on these positive social behaviors, more behaviors like opening a garden hose. So what tells us is that, first of all, oxytocin is a deep part of our human nature. It's what it means to be a human is to be a social creature. But to be social, we have to have some chemical,
一旦他们释放了催产素，我们就会发现，我们实际上可以像打开花园水管一样开启这些积极的社会行为、更多的行为。所以这告诉我们，首先，催产素是我们人性深处的一部分。做人意味着要成为一个社会生物。但要成为社会人，我们必须具备某种化学物质，
some indicator in our brain that tells us this person is safe, this person is someone I can affiliate with, this is someone I should care about, and that's what oxytocin seems to do. So it works in conjunction with other neurochemicals that maintain a balance between trust and distrust or fear, safety, approach, withdrawal. Can you alter the level of oxytocin in your brain? Or is that only something you can do in the lab? Or can you do it at home?
我们大脑中的某种指标，告诉我们这个人是安全的，这个人是我可以结交的，这个人是我应该关心的，这似乎就是催产素的作用。因此，它与维持信任与不信任或恐惧、安全、接近、回避之间平衡的其他神经化学物质协同工作。你能改变大脑中的催产素水平吗？还是这只能在实验室里做到？或者你在家里也能做到？
No, we're doing it all the time. So a simple thing like hugging will raise oxytocin. So a number of years ago, I decided to not shake people's hands, but hug everybody. and people would connect better with me actually. And so... Surprisingly. Yeah, surprisingly. And so anything that really reaches out and connects you to other people will likely
不，我们一直在这样做。所以像拥抱这样简单的事情就会提高催产素。因此，几年前，我决定不和别人握手，而是拥抱每个人。人们实际上会与我建立更好的联系。所以……令人惊讶。是的，令人惊讶。因此，任何真正伸出援手并将你与他人联系起来的事情都可能会
raise oxytocin. We've done a lot of field studies, for example, in the jungles of Papua New Guinea, taking blood from people who live in the rainforest after they do a tribal dance, and the majority of those individuals release oxytocin. I've gone to weddings and taken blood from the bride and the groom in the wedding party, and that wedding ritual not only released oxytocin on average, but it does so in a very particular manner. You know, who's the center of the wedding and solar system?
提高催产素。我们做过很多实地研究，例如在巴布亚新几内亚的丛林中，从生活在雨林中的人在跳完部落舞蹈后提取血液，其中大多数个体都释放了催产素。我去参加过婚礼，从新娘、新郎以及婚礼派对成员身上提取血液，结果发现婚礼仪式不仅平均释放了催产素，而且是以非常独特的方式释放的。你知道，婚礼太阳系的中心是谁？
The bride, of course, is the biggest increase in oxytocin. Who loves the wedding almost as much as the bride? Her mother, right? So she's number two. And so the release of oxytocin, the amount of release tells us about the strength of connections between individuals. So who are the best oxytocin relicers, little children, puppies, you know, people who need our support to survive.
当然是新娘，催产素的增加幅度最大。谁对婚礼的喜爱几乎不亚于新娘？是她的母亲，对吧？所以她是第二名。因此，催产素的释放量告诉我们个体之间联系的强度。那么，谁是最好的催产素释放者？小孩子、小狗，你知道的，那些需要我们的支持才能生存的人。
But I think we all can actually release oxytocin in other. So we can't cause our own brain to release oxytocin in general. There's some exceptions, but we can give that gift to others. So I think one of the take-homes is, as a social creature, you need to reach out, connect to others, give them that gift of oxytocin release, and most likely 95% of the thousands of people we study, they will reciprocate. So the people who don't are essentially of two types. One is people who are super stressed out, they're having a bad day, they just don't have the brain activity
但我认为我们大家实际上都可以在其他人身上释放催产素。所以一般情况下，我们无法让自己的大脑释放催产素。有一些例外，但我们可以把这份礼物送给别人。因此，我认为带回家的要点之一是，作为一个社会生物，你需要伸出援手，与他人联系，给他们带来催产素释放的礼物，很可能在我们研究的数千人中，有95%的人会回报。所以不这样做的人基本上分为两类。一类是超级压力山大、度过糟糕一天的人，他们根本没有大脑活动
to actually release oxytocin. And the second is psychopaths. So a study of psychopaths shows that they don't really. this oxytocin, and they don't have the antecedent psychological effects of oxytocin release, which is that feeling of empathy. So that's classically missing in psychopaths. So when we connect to others, we better reflect their emotions, which helps us be better social creatures to understand how to interact with them.
来真正释放催产素。第二类是精神病患者。因此，对精神病患者的研究表明，他们并没有真正做到这一点。这种催产素，而且他们没有催产素释放的先决心理影响，也就是同理心的感觉。所以这在精神病患者身上是典型缺失的。因此，当我们与他人建立联系时，我们能更好地反映他们的情绪，这有助于我们成为更好的社会生物，去理解如何与他们互动。
And you're talking about things that are very much about face-to-face interactions. How have our brains adapted to more frequent interactions via social media and online networking? How is all this coming into play? That's a great question. So we've done a couple of small-scale studies. We came in, had people give us a sample of their blood, and then let them in private use social media of any type. Twitter, Facebook, emailing, and then took their blood 10 minutes later.
你谈论的事情很大程度上与面对面互动有关。我们的神经系统是如何适应通过社交媒体和在线网络进行更频繁的互动的？这一切是如何发挥作用的？这是一个很好的问题。所以我们做了一些小规模的研究。我们进来，让人们给我们提供他们的血液样本，然后让他们在私密状态下使用任何类型的社交媒体。推特、脸书、发邮件，然后在10分钟后提取他们的血液。
What we found was that in 100% of the people we've tested so far, social media use causes the brain release oxytocin. And, as I said earlier, the amount of oxygen release tells us about the strength of connection. So we did this recently for a Korean TV station, and we included one of their young producers in the sample. It must have been 22 or 23 years old. And when we got his results from his blood test back, he had 150% increase in oxytocin.
我们发现，在我们迄今为止测试的100%的人中，使用社交媒体会导致大脑释放催产素。而且，正如我之前所说，氧气的释放量（注：原文口误，指催产素）告诉我们联系的强度。所以我们最近为一个韩国电视台做过这件事，我们在样本中包括了他们的一位年轻制作人。他大概22或23岁。当我们拿回他的血液测试结果时，他的催产素增加了150%。
So I said, you know, I don't know what this guy was doing because he was using social media in private. My guess was he was interacting with his mother or his girlfriend because the connection was so powerful. They checked. He was posting to his girlfriend's Facebook page for 10 minutes. So again, think about this. chemical as giving us the ability to determine who we should invest our resources in, who we should
所以我说，你知道，我不知道这家伙在做什么，因为他在私密状态下使用社交媒体。我猜他是在和他的母亲或女朋友互动，因为这种联系太强烈了。他们查了。他在他女朋友的脸书主页上发了10分钟的帖子。所以再次想想，这种化学物质赋予了我们能力，让我们能够决定应该将资源投入到谁身上，我们应该
be vulnerable to, who we should trust who we want to be around. And that's very adaptive for social creatures. Now, another thing you found at the Center for Neuroeconomic Studies, and what is neuroeconomics? How does it help us learn about human behavior? Right. So I know that you have never made a bad decision in your life, but your brother-in-law who started buying investment real estate in 2007, when everyone knew the bubble was going to crash, what's the deal on that? So neuro-economic studies, brain activity while people make decisions. That's it. Many of those decisions have to do with decisions that may involve products or markets, but a lot of them don't. So much of our research has been on social decisions, so interact strongly
对谁敞开心扉，我们应该信任谁，我们想和谁在一起。这对于社会生物来说是非常适应性的。现在，你在神经经济学研究中心发现的另一件事是，什么是神经经济学？它如何帮助我们了解人类行为？好的。所以我知道你一生中从未做出过错误的决定，但是你的连襟在2007年开始购买投资性房地产时，当时所有人都知道泡沫会破裂，这到底是怎么回事？所以神经经济学研究的是人们做决定时的大脑活动。就是这样。其中许多决定与涉及产品或市场的决定有关，但很多则不然。我们的很多研究都是关于社会决策的，因此与社会心理学领域的互动很强，
with areas in social psychology, as well as with solving problems. How do people actually solve problems as a group or as individuals, which interacts with cognitive psychology? So many of the studies we've done have a very strong psychological component to them because we not only want to understand the brain activity and the behavior, but what it feels like, what's the subjective experience of going through this? And so we use a lot of tools from psychology to really understand what human beings are doing. Well, great. Thank you so much, Dr. Zach, for being with us today. It was a pleasure. For more information on Dr. Zach's work, please visit our website at Speaking of Psychology.
同时也与解决问题有关。人们实际上是如何作为一个群体或作为个体来解决问题的，这与认知心理学相互作用。因此，我们做的许多研究都有很强的心理学成分，因为我们不仅想了解大脑活动和行为，还想了解它的感觉是什么，经历这个过程的主观体验是什么？因此，我们使用了许多心理学工具来真正理解人类在做什么。好的，太棒了。非常感谢扎克博士今天来到我们这里。非常荣幸。有关扎克博士工作的更多信息，请访问我们的网站“心理学访谈”。
With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与美国心理学协会合作，“心理学访谈”，我是安德烈·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。